welcome to this video playing fantozzi
from Tolzien Igor tipley okay it's got
no flick yeah I don't know the guy let's
see maybe something sharp to wake me up
having my morning coffee right now but I
don't feel like wide awake ok I take
here and d6 one good reply against the
Blumenfeld here with Bishop g5 I think
white can go even for on and now a 684
Bishop e7 I think this is how is played
but no expert this still looks okay now
threatening night takes d5 so um okay
you can just ignore it or really now
maybe maybe you can ignore it and just
take take b5 as a as a compensation in a
way of ya can probably do that but still
I should probably play the move here
honey it's a central pawn after all and
after the capture may be cancelled so so
that Bishop e2 f9f for maybe and on
other bishop moves I can move the night
yeah to f4 to be 6 yeah here Knight b6
could be an idea so that i can actually
attack it and maybe can take on b5 hmm
not sure that night f4 is really leading
to anything I'm not really attacking on
the kingside could be just misplaced
them
yeah here I probably can just take b5
now if everything else fails taking on
c4 is really much not really good leads
to development issues maybe just do that
simple approach so the night back to be
six or to c7 I guess back to be six
covering c-45 yeah we have equal
material and I've got those pawn to d6
and see 5d 6d six could be week at some
point but at the moment there's no
problem there is no direct attack coming
there cannot pressurize the pawn very
important is that he's got the night on
d two witches very very helpful for me
not on c3 that would be would be much
more active in fact maybe night f1 g3 or
not f1 III could be a good plan for wide
okay how do I play that here maybe I can
play c4 and Roxy five trying to isolate
the bishop okay he prevented this idea
yeah i can go knight c6 now but you will
probably capture yeah yeah still
probably probably right they are a very
simplistic way to play but certainly not
not too bad for what maybe i can just
take and go rook b6 to be for attacking
the c-4 pawn yeah should be even should
be possible
it's not much happening here rather an
exciting position okay so trying to
trying to get something here on their
only a down I can't go queen bee seven I
don't I don't know if I want to play g6
here yeah maybe does not seem to be a
substantial problem if you place rook e8
King g7 he also has to attend to his
background as a threatened Bishop c4
would be one this stuff and yeah okay
well i don't know i mean i play a play
look before very soon okay yeah Queen B
seven threatening would be one yeah
probably looks like the most most active
booth
now my dark squares a week but if I have
had played age six that would have good
Eve five controlling age 7 by the Queen
I'm not sure yeah well the threat of
rook be one short term should help me we
trade route siem then I don't have any
problem really because this back rank
problem is just going away at least then
I hope that this judgment is correct I'm
not totally sure what your test movers
okay this one yeah now Candace covers be
one now that's probably sensible
decision I go to be form now around and
I would attack that but maybe just try
to get rid of the rook this is really
making me nervous in the long run IAM
the Sun okay I can repeat and the
question is can I do more than
repetition yes this Queen f6 idea which
is fairly problem Madigan
I really don't see a good way to avoid
the repetition
time morning yeah I'm one minute down I
really don't see how to do this yeah I
don't really like to do those those kind
of short or hospet I mean I'm I'm more I
don't know I really don't don't don't
see em how I should should continue here
it's it's at least a bit like walking a
tightrope with one minute against two
minutes I can move the Queen away I mean
something like this is playable it's not
like I'm worse but I was very irritated
by this move him computer just gives
this as good for me yeah at least them
somewhat more comfortable maybe yeah
this is how how it should be played or
here we look at this here also have
different options I thought about this
move briefly but yeah I wasn't sure what
what is actually what is it actually
doing I mean queen before as would be
nice but rue ka diha he's playing move
like that and what then exactly
computers suggest age 16 h 7 you can do
that battle of one minute against two
yeah I guess this was the same decision
to take the draw he could have continued
maybe in regards the time I mean why
does absolutely not better but could
have done that it's about equal and why
not continue okay so a draw a bit of
uneventful uneventful game but it
somehow something sometimes it happens
maybe then g6 wasn't really good let me
briefly think about that yeah maybe I
should really prefer age 60 sorry we
look at this maybe still this I wasn't
bit irritated by this move but this
again threatens ruka area because
queen is controlling but I have this
very simple retreat or retreat is the
wrong word the simple covering move and
this is actually now really nice for
black the no sorry white probably yeah
this is this is good for black actually
the bishop is just the better piece now
always having this pressure against the
pawn something like this there are some
ideas here after after preparation maybe
both f6 or g6 this is this is really
better than g6 it's not like brilliant
but here black can claim with thumb some
own justification to be slightly better
okay thanks for watching